المشروبات الغازيه مهدده بالنفاذ من على
رفوف المتاجر بسبب الحرب في السودان اذ
تعتمد في صناعتها على الصمغ العربي دون
وجود بديل عن هذه الماده 70% من امدادات
العالم من الصمغ العربي تاتي من السودان
تحديدا من شجره الاكاسيا في منطقه الساحل
الشركات الكبرى مثل كوكاكولا وبيبسي كولا
دخلت في سباق لدعم امداداتها معتمده على
مخزونها الحالي والذي يغطي ما بين ثلاثه
الى سته اشهر فقط
الموضوع يقلق الشركات المنتجه بشكل عام
فالصمغ العربي يدخل ايضا في صناعه السلع
الاستهلاكيه كالحلوى ومواد التجميل
[موسيقى]
استثنته الولايات المتحده من العقوبات
التي تفرضها على السودان منذ التسعينيات
فهل تكون الوجبات السريعه مستقبلا دون
البطاطس المقليه والمشروبات الغازيه
[موسيقى]